Film Courage: When should a writer quit their
full-time job?
Erik Bork, Screenwriter/Author: Only when
writing has become one that can replace that
full-time job basically I would say which
you kind of know it when it happens I think.
Obviously if you have a full time job because
you need that amount of income and you can’t
get it if you quit because writing isn’t
bringing it then I probably wouldn’t be
quitting.
I think most people tend to get it.
I don’t see people quitting their jobs even
when they have a professional nibble at writing
because you can have a nibble that doesn’t
turn into anything.
Even if you get an agent, even if you get
a job, even if you get a job on writing staff
of a hit show that could be over in six months
and you may not get another one.
You’re going to suspend your full-time day
job while you’re on that hit show because
you probably have to go to work every day
on the show at the office you know with the
rest of the writers but I would say it’s
great if you have other ways to earn a living
that you like and that have growth potential
and no reason to let those go but there may
come a time where you have to stop because
I’m writing on a movie and they need me
full-time for the next six months and they’re
paying me half a million dollars or whatever.
Film Courage: That would be a good problem
to have.
What about the notion that people have where
I just need six months, I’m going to take
this time off and this is going to go great.
I’ll get up everyday and I have this regimen,
this practice.
I’m going to crank these pages out.
Do you think this really works?
Or do you think it’s this romantic version
of writing?
Erik: I don’t know if it works.
I’ve never really done that.
It maybe works sometimes for some people.
I am more of a believer that you carve out
time in your regular life every day or like
five days a week.
So if that means getting up early for an hour.
I mean Ron Bass used to be a lawyer and the
story was that he would wake up at 3:00 a.m.
and write for four hours and then go and be
an entertainment lawyer all day back before
he was a famous screenwriter.
But even an hour at night, an hour at lunch,
whatever, half hour, every Saturday and Sunday
for two hours each and then although that
I think is not as good as five days a week
but the idea of I’m going to take this time
off and then when this time is over, I don’t
have time to write anymore I don’t think
tends to work as well.
That’s not to say you can’t take a retreat
for a week or a month.
I think John August does that, he goes to
a hotel in Las Vegas to pump out a first draft
in three weeks or whatever like a change of
scenery or getting away from the normal daily
responsibilities can work but I think it works
best combined with you also have a daily writing
practice and you’re moving it forward every
day in some way as well.
Film Courage: Do you think the notion of wanting
to take this long stretch of time out is actually
damaging because you lose touch with the day-to-day?
Because when you’re not working or you are
on vacation your mind is not in the reality
of the day-to-day.
Your stressors are different.
You’re not worrying about being on someone
else’s time schedule which you are when
you have a job?
You are at the mercy of their schedule pretty
much.
Do you lose touch with writing [when this
happens]?
Erik: When you’re saying when you go off
and write and you leave your regular life
will your writing not be as good because you’re
out of touch with regular life?
Film Courage: Pretty much, yes.
Erik: I don’t really see that as an issue.
I think it’s okay to not be currently immersed
in your normal life to be able to write.
I think it’s just more a danger that just
somebody never writes until they have that
magical stretch of time where they think they
are going to write all day, every day and
it’s going to be great.
I think most writers who are professionals
tend to more have a block of time they do
it every day to maybe a shorter block but
they are always kind of doing it and moving
it forward.
Question For The Viewers: When should a writer
quit their day job?